nous magali zamora les secrétaire
général cgt m santé et membre de
l'intersyndicale martinique
bonjour merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france à l'europe la proposition
de la médiatrice a donc été retenue il
ya le report de l'obligation vaccinale à
des soignants et la gratuité des tests
sont donc les deux préconisations
retenues par le gouvernement
comment avez vous accueilli cette
annonce plutôt bonne nouvelle ou
finalement ça ne règle pas le problème
de fond
le problème de fond sont toujours
content obligations persie d'aller
installer terre aujourd'hui nous avons
connaissance
d'allemand a adopté
une communication
walla est et c'est dommage nous avons
nous considérons que c'est un manque de
respect vis-à-vis de nous martiniquais
toutes les personnes piquées il s'est
passé de fonctionner de communiquer les
bacs 70 cela dit nous avons nous appris
cette décision mais nous savons ce n'est
pas une fin en soi et que la rupture
poursuivi on continue parce qu'avec ce
gouvernement là beaucoup d'incohérences
aujourd'hui nous savons qu'il ya des
ruptures de la confiance en tout cas de
l'outre-mer vis-à-vis de ce gouvernement
qui n'arrête pas de nous mentir il
n'avait pas de guérison et qu'il était
passé parole alors qu'elle elle mourra
landes une personnel soignant martin qui
avait le moral il est vraiment abbès est
ce que nous voyons que aujourd'hui les
taux le taux de non vaccinés est
important ne parle pas de 38% de biens
de personnes vaccinées dont vous voyez
que aujourd'hui les faits sont là et on
ne peut pas on recrutera constituent des
soins ou à penser de pouvoir travailler
ou laissés ouverts les services sans les
personnels soignants ce n'est pas
possible et aujourd'hui nous avons des
personnes sont aussi assimilé au ciel de
soigneurs nous avons les bases des
gravasses ils les ont
ainsi nous avons les pompiers est rendu
catastrophe sanitaire social qui menace
au niveau de départements non dans les
difficultés en que le personnel soignant
guadeloupéen rencontrant vous l'avez
dire en moral haut ou plus bas il ya
aussi un manque de matériel est ce que
finalement la pandémie en l'actuelle
pandémie a juste mis en lumière les
problèmes que les hôpitaux martinique
rencontre déjà depuis des années
maintenant
alors cinq locataires avaient à ce
compte est automatique des prédications
de longues années il a vomi toute alerte
et il est effet justement et nous
savions pertinemment de la fnti avant
crise assez difficile ça nous a piqués
au lavo le constat était rayé les
parents ont commis 10 sont aujourd'hui
que tout ce que nous avons découpé
fermeture ou la suppression des
effectifs démantèlement ces risques du
grand lyon nous sommes en plein dedans
et nous voyons que le gouvernement de
cette logique économie poursuit sa
politique qui n'est pas en faveur de la
santé a posé santé parce qu'on veut
faire des économies sur la santé ce
n'est pas aussi alors je vais revenir
sur les propos de danielle toupillier
c'est la médiatrice dans un cas a été
mandatée début novembre en martinique
elle affirmé ma mission est terminée
même si nous ne sommes jamais rentrés
formellement en médiation comme nous
l'espérions que ça veut dire quoi
parce qu'en fait le périmètre la
médiation au départ nous avons compris
que le
mission avec les cadrages circonscrit au
chum et nous savons pas aujourd'hui le
conflit social dans lequel nous sommes
aujourd'hui ne sont pas connues il faut
savoir que nous sommes dans un
groupement hospitalier
qui s'annoncent en hausse qui s'explique
et nous avons différents établissements
avant le social et médico-social toutes
les structures qui sont adossés aux cinq
ans plus tard et deux parties rico aussi
concernés donc nous aurions engagé une
médiation pour uniquement comme
dailymotion ce n'est pas possible
magali zamor merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général cgt m santé et membre
de l'inter syndicale martinique merci à
vous d'avoir été en direct sur arte
france